[Musique]
Washington réputé pour être plus à
gauche que la moyenne et il pratiquait
depuis les années 60-70 qu'ils
appelaient une journée d'absence où ils
encouragaient de façon non coercitive
une revendication de la part de
certaines minorités non blanches était
de dire on ne va pas aller sur le campus
pendant cette journée d'absence pour
vous faire comprendre que vous nous
remarquez quand on est plus là
et en 2017 il renverse la journée
d'absence il le transforme en une
journée où les blancs sont interdits de
campus et on a un professeur breath one
Stein fan de Burny Sanders un vrai
progressisme et qui dans un mail très
bien rédigé
très bien argumenté explique que ce
n'est pas la même chose il s'est opposé
à cette mesure
on a des étudiants qui commencent à
faire du grabuge
à traiter brettoyenstein ou de
suprématiste blanc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on n'est pas là pour débattre toi tu es
là pour te taire et tu es là pour nous
écouter
donc en tant que blanc homme de plus de
50 ans on sait déjà ce que vous avez à
nous dire vous n'avez rien à nous
apprendre donc vous ne savez pas que
vous vivez dans un monde
structurellement raciste sexiste etc
donc cyniquement Vous vous opposez en
fait à la révolution parce que vous
savez que vous allez perdre votre
privilège
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et qu'est-ce qui se passe craignant pour
leur sécurité qui du coup de fait
n'était plus garantie breath Winston et
sa femme tous deux biologistes
quitte le campus et dans les journées
qui suivent on a des étudiants donc on
est mi-juin 2017 qui rôde sur le campus
armé de battre de baseball et de tes
heures à la recherche de ce qu'ils
appellent le suprématiste blanc et de
breath Winston en particulier
sur le campus qui l'ont quitté en juin
2017 ils ont fait un procès et ils l'ont
gagné et Evergreen forcément de par son
image a été lourdement affectée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où vous êtes avec moi où vous êtes
contre moi United
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des années 60-70 c'est aussi l'arrivée
sur les campus américains de ce qu'on a
appelé la french théorie c'est-à-dire
l'éruption de Deleuze Foucault
Derrida qui est une véritable star
là-bas puisque on imprime des t-shirts à
son effigie donc c'est une sorte de
prince de la pensée et d'emblée
s'installe un grand malentendu sur les
messages apportés par les philosophes
français le premier acte de la frenchère
c'est en gros la thèse de Foucault qui
l'analysait sous différentes formes
méfiez-vous méfiez-vous
du pouvoir et des Rida a ajouté quelque
chose de très important comme
tout pouvoir tout hiérarchie et tout
savoir
sont des constructions sociales qui
arrangent les gens de pouvoir il faut
tout déconstruire
walking non
tractions
malentendu qui va se jouer entre ces
différents philosophes et la pensée
nord-américaine c'est pour ces
philosophes ce qui compte c'est la
dissolution du sujet c'est l'abolition
du mois et c'est donc la disparition des
identités et aux Etats-Unis la pensée de
Foucault de Derrida Deleuze et de
Bourdieu va être vu comme au contraire
une manière d'enraciner les individus
dans leur communauté d'origine ou dans
leur orientation sexuelle et à partir de
là le contresens va être complet et les
et la théorie française la french
théorie va revenir des États-Unis à la
France après 30 ans de maturation mais
elle va revenir sous un autre aspect
c'est à dire l'obsession de la race du
genre et d'identité
[Musique]
j'ai une passion pour Romain Gary
et puis Romain Gary c'est un regard sur
le monde profondément humain
profondément universaliste et qui pointe
aussi avec acidité avec ironie à travers
ses mots
les dérèglements sémantiques et les
dérèglements de la bataille contre
l'antisémitisme ou contre contre les
discriminations
[Musique]
chien blanc alors qu'il a écrit dans les
années 70 mais c'est d'une modernité
folle par rapport à ce qu'on peut vivre
aujourd'hui avec ces dérives sectaires
c'est vrai que là il nous parle des
Black Panthers et notamment bon de
Malcom X qui va diviser aussi des
États-Unis alors que la Libye c'était de
réparer les États-Unis c'était de
réparer cette question raciale mais au
fond il nous fait comprendre Romain Gary
que les États-Unis sont fondés sur la
séparation entre les races et sont
fondées sur les discriminations
ou vous situez votre livre chez un blanc
il n'y a quand même danger de mettre sur
le même plan d'égalité le racisme des
lois et le racisme des blancs
je la recuse absolument totalement la
dialectique qui consiste les Noirs ont
été maintenues par une cirque dans des
conditions abandonnables donc ils ont le
droit d'être à 6 0 pour la question ce
qui me survenu d'une amitié parmi les
Noirs américains je m'en contre fou le
le représailles raciste au nom du
racisme c'est de la connerie la plus
dégueulasse que l'humanité est jamais
connu et noir jaune tchao grec en latin
ou merde à part entière c'est un
raisonnement que je n'accepte pas si
vous avez été victime du racisme votre
premier devoir être ne pas être raciste
[Musique]
l'après midi eu lieu dans la maison d'un
professeur d'Ardres dramatique
[Musique]
une réunion de libéraux engagée dans la
lutte pour les droits civiques
s'agissait d'éclairer certains blancs
cossus sur le degré atteint par la haine
des blancs dans le psychisme des enfants
noirs
on avait donc organisé une petite
démonstration en faisant venir quelques
gosses âgés de 7 8 et 9 ans dont les
parents étaient présents
et voici dans une transcription dont je
garantis l'authenticité le dialogue
entre les enfants noirs et une dame
blanche qui était non seulement leur ami
mais hébergé chez elle toute cette
famille de militants père mère et les
cinq petits
suis-je une sale blanche
yES man you are honki wimdam vous êtes
une sale blanche de you heate me Jimmy
est-ce que tu me hais le compte rendu
note profond soupir de l'enfant
yES man je vous hais i hate you après
une hésitation il ajoute
sorof en quelque sorte
en réalité le brave jimin est personne
et la preuve c'est qu'après je vous hais
il ne peut s'empêcher d'ajouter sordoff
ce qui veut dire en quelque sorte il
revient à avouer que dans cet effet
violence en disant oui je vous hais
cette scène là elle est folle en plus
parce qu'il demande à un enfant et c'est
vrai qu'elle préfigure totalement ce qui
tente de s'imposer aujourd'hui à la fois
cette culpabilité blanche extrêmement
mal placée parce que dans cette
culpabilité là ce sont c'est quand même
les femmes blanches qui donnent l'ordre
qu'on les insulte en tout cas c'est elle
qui décide de quand elles vont se faire
insulter je ressens ça moi lorsque des
blancs disent ce mot mais vous en tant
que racisé j'ai jamais exactement
compris ce que recouvrait le terme
racisé mais de toute évidence et ce qui
n'est pas blanc dans ce cas là faut
définir le blanc est-ce que le blanc
c'est une couleur de peau est-ce que le
blanc c'est une mentalité ce que les
Asiatiques sont blancs est-ce que les
Juifs fond blanc qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire être blanc ce que ça veut dire
c'est
que lorsque vous êtes non blanc et bien
de toute façon vous êtes
assigné à résidence d'une discrimination
et même si vous ne l'avez pas encore été
on vous promet dès votre naissance que
vous allez subir de la discrimination
est-ce que vous avez jamais tenu ou
toléré des réunions en non-mexicains
lors de votre bureau national de l'UNEF
la question est simple donc très bien
laissez-moi expliquer
la question c'est pas est-ce qu'il y a
des réunions qui peuvent s'organiser les
réunions qui s'organisent dans l'UNEF en
mon mixité et ben effectivement il y en
a on mixité femme par exemple les femmes
de lunettes sont excité mais est-ce que
vous avez des réunions sont excluent
madame Luce la question est simple
d'accord vous voulez une réponse
laissez-moi la dire la réponse c'est que
aujourd'hui quand on est une femme on
subit des discriminations donc on
organise des réunions pour pouvoir pour
permettre aux femmes d'exprimer les
discriminations qu'elles peuvent subir
et on organise aussi des réunions pour
permettre aux personnes qui sont
effectivement touchés par le racisme de
pouvoir exprimer ce qu'elle subit
ou les non blancs ne sont pas admis et
les blancs ne sont pas émis c'est ça
mais
oui ou non ça veut dire
donc est-ce que ça existe mais je viens
de vous expliquer que ça existe ça
existe comment les femmes ont parlé
entre elles quand elles ont commencé à
réfléchir sur leurs conditions après bon
voie ça m'a pas choqué à l'époque mais
est-ce que c'est un syndicat d'étudiant
d'organiser effectivement ces rencontres
racisées chanter
ou autre oui c'est la bonne question
salut je m'appelle
Omar
ancrée dans notre société un système qui
oppose les dominants et les deux les
dominants étant un similaire de
personnes blanches et les domaines
être racisée c'est être un opprimé
c'était issu des anciennes colonies
c'est être une minorité dans un pays
occidental et de toute évidence dans ces
minorités là les juifs et les Asiatiques
sont exclus ce qui déjà montrent à quel
point toute cette théorie que moi
j'appelle ça un peu l'idéologie de la
mélanine et d'un racisme qui se fait
passer pour un antiracisme et donc ce
mot-là est extrêmement je le qualifie
comme un mot extrêmement dangereux un
mot qui nous sépare un mot qui déchire
notre société et pour moi ce langage là
c'est le langage du début du séparatisme
il y a une femme ancienne ministre qui
m'a écrit en me disant il faut que tu te
souviennes à Sita que tu es noir et il
faut que tu n'oublies pas les autres
noirs et je me suis dit mais salut sinon
moi je ne pense jamais en termes de
couleurs de peau et je ne parle jamais
sur la base de ma couleur de peau je
suis une personne je suis avant tout à
cet art ce qu'il nous semblait par
exemple un progrès à avoir l'effacement
du de la couleur des gens pour en juger
a été retourné complètement absolument
si vous ne reconnaissez pas nos couleurs
différentes
c'est que vous êtes raciste la culture
wow qui est en guerre contre la norme et
je dirais en l'occurrence les normes qui
sont celles de l'Occident donc des
blancs et du coup
pour combattre le racisme qui est une
sorte de peste épouvantable
malgré j'imagine leur objectif ils sont
peut-être en train d'en créer un autre
et
c'est à dire le racisme antiblant j'ai
l'impression aussi que ceux qui
prétendent aujourd'hui combattre le
racisme et qui qui parle tout le temps
de ce sujet là sont en fait ceux qui
nous enferment dans notre couleur de
peau parce qu'en gros on devrait
dépasser ça parce que là il y a vraiment
cette couleur qui fait qui fait écran et
qui fait qu'ils vont jamais chercher à
savoir qui vous êtes je trouve que c'est
assez limité comme vision de l'être
humain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le mouvement Black sazemateur n'est sous
Barack Obama après une importance
primordiale au moment d'affaires Georges
foï donc de ce noir américain qui a été
étouffé sous le genou d'un policier
qu'il a délibérément tué devant l'oeil
des caméras et qui donc a été ensuite
arrêté qui a provoqué cette vague
d'émeute incroyable que l'on a vu
pendant tous l'été 2020 et alors ayant
acquis une véritable valeur
institutionnelle black 16 matter et
devenu un référent incontournable de la
vie politique
nord-américaine avec toutes les dérives
que ça entraîne dans toutes les émeutes
qui ont
atteint les grandes villes
pendant cet été là on a vu que le ce
mouvement antiraciste a ciblé aussi deux
catégories de citoyens les Juifs donc
énormément de synagogues ont été tagués
des commerces juifs ont été brûlés des
croix gammées ont été tagués dans les
quartiers au nom de la lutte contre le
sionisme et Israël et puis aussi
beaucoup de commerces asiatiques ont été
attaqués puisque traditionnellement dans
les émeutes à foi américaines des
asiatiques sont très souvent ciblés
comme étant des profiteurs comme étant
en quelque sorte des supplétifs des
blancs
voilà ils sont un milliards
[Musique]
je trouve que c'est un mot très
important et très pertinent être une
personne en situation de handicap être
lesbienne et noir et juive et de faire
avec nos singularités ça c'est
intéressant parce que ça montre qu'on
était pas qu'une seule couche justement
oui ça commence par le racialisme oui ça
commence par la condition noire on est
aux États-Unis c'est pas étonnant et
puis peu à peu ça c'est le premier sens
je dirais de l'intersectionnalité peu à
peu les autres minorités qui se sentent
des minorités
discriminées ce sont juin ensemble sauf
que cette notion là a été récupérée
pour en faire quelque chose de
désastreux c'est à dire ne pas faire
avec l'intersectionnalité mais de faire
véritablement avec un dogme qui vous
enferme et en tant que féministe
intersectionnel vous devez penser comme
ça je pensais que c'était une notion
ouverte alors que ça devient une notion
fermée c'est étonnant parce que
l'intersectionnalité quand on est dans
une intersection on est un rond-point on
est dans quelque chose qui s'ouvre sur
différents chemins là
l'intersectionnalité ne trouve pas de
solution sur un chemin qui permettrait
de résoudre nos problématiques de
l'humanité c'est un c'est un cul-de-sac
donc des gens qui disent tout ce qui
doit être un texte intersectionnel ça
vient de cette idée d'aphro-féminisme de
de d'islamo féminisme de choses comme ça
pour moi le féminisme il est universel
j'ai lu six mois de Beauvoir j'avais 11
ans pourquoi parce que j'étais obsédée
par la liberté je ne comprenais pas
pourquoi j'étais traité différemment en
tant que fille pourquoi à l'âge de 5 ans
j'ai été j'ai été pourquoi je devais
faire toutes les tâches ménagères je me
posais beaucoup de questions et j'ai
découvert un passage de de d'un livre de
Simone de Beauvoir qui m'a intrigué je
n'ai pas tout compris la première fois
mais ce que j'ai compris c'était une
chose qu'une femme qui n'est même pas ma
couleur de peau qui habite dans un pays
que je ne peux pas situer sur la carte
donc j'ignorais l'existence parce que à
cet âge-là pour moi il y avait que le
Burkina Faso qui existait on était à la
campagne on n'est pas de télé on avait
la radio RFI mais je sais pas d'où ça
venait moi RFI
alors à ce moment-là je crois qu'il n'y
a rien de plus universel que ça que la
liberté ça existe dans un langage qu'on
comprend même si on est différent et
c'est grâce à cette femme à Simone de
Beauvoir à son livre que moi j'ai
compris que j'avais le droit d'être
libre et que j'ai également compris
qu'on pouvait se battre pour la liberté
pas seulement pour soi mais aussi pour
tout le monde dans la société
[Musique]
on met toujours la focale sur les
quartiers populaires les quartiers
populaires sont en déficit de
connaissance de conscience politique il
faut les éduquer etc et on
oculte complètement le reste de la
société et c'est privilèges les
privilèges du reste de la société et moi
j'ai envie de dire c'est le reste de la
société qu'il faut éduquer c'est le
reste de la société à qui il faut dire
par exemple ne serait-ce que sur la
question de l'histoire c'est c'est le
reste de la société
occidentale de ce qu'on appelle nous les
sushis puisque il faut bien leur donner
un nom les blancs il faut éduquer donc
faut arrêter ce chien je pense que c'est
le mot le peut-être le plus atroce de
cette novlang
qui est une un mot qui a été
consacré par les Indigènes de la
République qui est une réponse en fait
aux Français de souche de l'extrême
droite vous savez moi je suis musulmane
par mon père et juif par ma mère
aujourd'hui le Juif est devenu ce super
blanc ce super dominant
mais parce que là on est aussi à la
croisée du complotisme et du fait que
voilà dans l'imaginaire le Juif c'est
celui qui allait super pouvoir qui a
l'argent le Juif est un dominant le juif
ne fait plus partie des minorités et
donc ça permet de mettre toute forme
d'antisémitisme sous le tapis en disant
c'est antisémitisme est une défense
contre
le presseur qui est devenu le Juif une
arme pour se défendre contre cette
puissance juive la seule communauté qui
meurt en France demeure violente ce sont
des Juifs parce que Juifs qu'importe 67
milliards de Kippour ils sont passés de
opprimé à oppresseurs et ces deux
petites évidence définitifs
Ilan alimy ce jeune vendeur de 23 ans
a-t-il été séquestré torturé tué par ce
qu'il était juif édition spéciale sur
cette fusillade dans une école juive à
Toulouse un homme casqué a tué
froidement 4 personnes dont trois jeunes
enfants l'émotion est immense la
campagne électorale est mise entre
parenthèses Nicolas Sarkozy évoque une
tragédie nationale et annonce que le
plan Vigipirate est porté au niveau
maximum
de suspects ont été mises en examen pour
le meurtre de Mireille Knoll
l'octogénaire tué à coup de couteau et
retrouvé dans son appartement
sur les réseaux sociaux de ce mouvement
wok on commémore régulièrement la mort
de certaines personnes comme par exemple
la mort de Ibrahim Ali dans les années
80 un jeune Marseillais qui a été tué
par des colorés à Marseille mais en
l'occurrence
il y a un énorme silence pour
l'antisémitisme qui est le résultat de
l'islamisme radical
[Musique]
c'est que
à l'époque en fait de la lutte pour les
droits civiques aux États-Unis
ma mère est partie aux États-Unis ma
mère juive parce qu'on est obligé de
dire que ma mère juive est parti aux
États-Unis sur ses batailles-là ou en
fait juifs et afro-américains étaient
ensemble sur les droits civiques et
étonnamment les décoloniaux
intersectionnelles wow que tout ça
ne part jamais cette histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au pouvoir de Baba il y a de la part des
ambassades en Europe une sorte de
volonté messianique d'éduquer les
Européens à la sagesse américaine parce
que l'Amérique reste un empire et qui
dit empire dit impérialisme il y a un
sauf power américain qui est tout sauf
qui est extrêmement intrusif et
l'ambassade des États-Unis en France
évidemment attendant ça allait chercher
systématiquement des jeunes gens dans
les banlieues et
cette volonté un peu humanitaire au
départ de d'aller aider les jeunes issus
des minorités c'est très vite transformé
en croisade ce que les Américains
considéraient que nous étions nous
d'affreux racistes et eux qui étaient
les chevaliers blancs qui allaient
apporter la vertu et c'est vrai que moi
j'ai été contacté
par la Maison Blanche que je suis partie
en 2013 je crois aux états sur ces
thèmes là de l'égalité on a fait
plusieurs États et ce qui était fou dans
dans ma situation c'est que ça m'a donné
encore plus envie de me raccrocher à nos
fondamentaux français et européen puis
je voyais surtout cette histoire qui
n'est pas du tout la nôtre fondée sur de
tels injustices structurellement ils
sont fabriqués comme ça ils sont
fabriqués sur la race sur la question de
la race et pas nous et puis ensuite
c'est vrai que j'ai vu
en très peu de temps
beaucoup l'appellent l'importation de
ces idéologies wok mais moi je parle
d'une colonisation alors on est
absolument pas dans la même culture
Rokhaya là vous vous êtes à Washington
avec des parlementaires ou le mot noir
est tout sauf un gros mot et c'est
absolument pas discriminatoire est-ce
que vous aimeriez que ce système existe
en France moi j'ai participé ce donc ce
matin à une table ronde qui réunissait
plusieurs participants français dont des
élus noirs tels que le modem alain
Dolium et une association française
toute récente qui s'appelle le caucus de
la diversité en Europe qui a décidé
d'aller à la rencontre de ce black opus
aux États-Unis pour importer leur
méthode et s'inspirer de leurs actions
en Europe les cadeaux de diffusion
privilégiés par le walkisme sont déjà
bien évidemment le monde universitaire
parce qu'ils ont besoin quand même
d'un vernis de légitimité d'autorité
scientifiques pour
diffuser et pour légitimer les idées de
façon beaucoup plus je dirais massive et
concrète c'est souvent des médias jeunes
des médias en ligne qui ensuite vont
vulgariser ces concepts et les diffuser
à très grande échelle et c'est là qu'on
peut parler d'une certaine influence
idéologique puisque en France les jeunes
qui étaient sensibles à ces questions
ils ont puisé dans ces mouvements-là
black climater me too pour ramener ces
questions là en France willow Smith ou
qui est la fille de Will Smith et de
Jada Pinkett Smith de part sa famille et
l'influence qu'elle a dans le monde de
la musique ou du cinéma elle se fait le
relais de cette idéologie c'est-à-dire
que non seulement elle pense ce qu'il
faut penser mais en plus elle est classe
elle est belle elle est dans une famille
de superstar donc elle a de l'influence
[Musique]
par exemple avec sa grand-mère et sa
mère elle vous invitait des blanches
pour discuter pour qu'elle se confronte
à leur privilège blanc c'est les
institutions qui organisent le racisme
cette personne qui est perçue comme
blanche si tenté que ça veut dire
quelque chose oui de certains privilèges
ou du moins elle en est complice ce qui
va nécessairement
et ça a été mon cas créer un sentiment
de culpabilité profond parce que on se
dit mais je je fais rien et si je fais
rien bah je je suis lâche ou je suis
dans le déni
et donc à partir de ce moment là on peut
se laisser complètement embarquer par
ces comptes là qui vont dire mais
attends attends
oui tu es blanc mais tu peux faire
quelque chose tu peux devenir un allié
l'air humanitier une activiste
afro-américaine musulmane qui
revendiquent appartenir à la communauté
cuir donc LGBT elle c'est une figure
importante du mouvement Blackline matter
elle a un compte de plusieurs centaines
de milliers d'abonnés et les comptes en
France qui étaient sensibles à ces
questions là ce sont abonnés à elle
et ça a poussé certains comptes en
France à trouver des similitudes en fait
entre les les
injustices qui pouvaient se passer aux
États-Unis et les injustices qui
pouvaient avoir lieu en France
[Applaudissements]
on prend par exemple le cas de Georges
Floyd donc la mort d'un homme
afro-américain à la suite d'un contrôle
de police
on a tout de suite ramené ça à l'été
2020 à la faire Adama Traoré qui en 2016
est mort à la suite d'un contrôle de
police
Camille et Justine c'est donc deux
jeunes femmes qui sont des militantes
féministes elles sont aussi très
concernées par les questions
d'antirassismes et il y a quelques mois
elles ont posté une vidéo sur le
privilège blanc
elles sont avec une jeune femme une
humoriste qui est noire
nous allons parler du privilège blanc
elle nous questionne même pas en fait
l'existence du privilège blanc mais elle
l'a teste en partant du postulat que
certaines sociologues avaient théorisé
cette notion là si vous démarrez cette
vidéo en nous disant moi je ne vois pas
les couleurs je fais pas la peine pas la
peine comme c'est divertissant parce que
les vidéos sont sympas on n'a pas envie
de les contredire
c'est contre là par du principe que
il n'y a pas de débat à avoir dans la
mesure où on peut pas remettre en cause
un vécu une expérience ou qu'on doit
donner la parole aux personnes
concernées
elle considère que il n'y a pas de débat
à voir
pourquoi est-ce que cette génération si
touchez par le wokisme
je pense qu'il y a une
complexification du monde et une perte
de sens
qui génère une angoisse terrible et du
coup c'est précisément lorsque le monde
se complique et fait de moins en moins
sens que la promesse d'une simplicité
d'une binarité devient la plus
séduisante donc on voit gérer ce
phénomène ou le concept commence dans le
monde universitaire américain
arrive dans le monde universitaire
français et ensuite dégoulines si je
puis dire dans l'aspect culture de masse
et notamment à travers
ces médias jeunes et aussi l'aspect
culturel donc à travers Netflix
à travers Disney
[Musique]
dans les films et les séries et pour moi
s'il fallait le définir je dirais que
c'est l'exposition d'un mode de vie et
de valeur qui donne l'impression quand
tu regardes de fiction que c'est le
meilleur modèle possible et c'est ça
t'encourage à t'identifier voir à copier
l'école qu'on te présente et donc
Netflix a eu un retour de presse
sensationnel sur Orange is the new black
en partie parce que c'est exporte en 200
territoires c'est vu partout
et à partir de cette série qui a été
érigée en exemple pendant toutes les
plateformes et toutes les chaînes
traditionnelles font un grand effort sur
les castings pour être sûr que chacun
est bien représenté
la diversité et la présentation c'est
une bonne chose ça permet aux acteurs
d'accéder à des rôles auxquels
chaque année la télévision américaine
fait un décompte
de genre de nationalité de ces
personnages et studios sont très
précautionneux ils veulent pas se
retrouver avec une polémique on va les
accuser de faire de faire des castings
trop blancs ou des campagnes de prix qui
te mettent en amont que des acteurs
d'origine caucasienne mais c'est vrai
que c'est une tendance maintenant à
insister pour que tout soit le plus
diversifié au possible
parfois le sujet de la série s'y prête
très bien et parfois ils s'y prête
beaucoup moins bien c'est comme ça qu'on
s'est retrouvé avec Bridgetown avec le
duc d'asting qui d'origine Caraïbes et
qui descendante d'une longue lignée de
du cnois
la seule information de la série pour
expliquer cette uchronie c'est de dire
la reine Charlotte on a tendance métier
donc on est dans un monde de la Régence
mais qui se comporte comme notre monde
du 21e siècle à nous ce qui peut être
parfois un petit peu confusionnant
la seconde femme d'Henri vite et ils ont
décidé de confier le rôle principal à
une actrice jamaicaine qui s'appelle
jeudi Turner Smith et ça fait beaucoup
de vagues parce qu'on sait les gens se
sont dit mais Anne Bollène tout le monde
voit le tableau de l'époque c'est une
femme très diaphane
ils ont fait un parallèle entre
l'aliénation mentale de cette femme au
16e siècle ou les pressions qu'on peut
subir quand on vient d'une minorité
qu'on est discriminé
finalement la fiction elle raconte
toujours le moment où elle a été créée
parce que les gens donnaient Netflix
croient vraiment tout le progressisme
qui vend je ne suis pas sûr est-ce
qu'ils veulent se faire des sourds et
c'est toujours très agréable d'être
salué comme un précurseur comme celui
qui a ouvert la marche et si dans le
même temps on vous dit que ça vous
paraît de mieux devant votre série enfin
c'est bonus sur toute la ligne
dans
une fessée
mais la question c'est est-ce qu'il a
une influence sur l'université alors on
ne peut pas dire que la majorité des
étudiants soient dans ce mouvement walk
mais il y a quand même certains faits
qui interroge avec certains étudiants
qui font pression pour annuler des
conférences qui seraient jugées trop
discriminatoires ou alors à l'inverse
des intitulés de cours qui pourraient
sembler vraiment marquer par certaines
idéologies à l'université c'est le
mouvement là se déploie dans quelle
proportion difficile à dire mais il est
important qu'il y ait un débat qu'il y a
un débat
qu'il n'y ait pas une logique
d'impunité ce qui a été un peu le cas
c'est-à-dire l'impunité ça veut dire que
on peut dire n'importe quoi que la
liberté académique c'est de dire
n'importe quoi et que la frontière
toujours subtile et compliquée entre le
discours savant et le militantisme
certains sociologues ils disent que non
non il faut être militant qui avait
cette frontière n'existe pas il y a des
collègues des départements de socio
certains collègues qui disent oui mais
nous sommes dans un racisme systémique
un racisme d'État etc tout simplement
mais vous êtes des fonctionnaires donc
vous êtes payé par cette étape raciste
je suis désolé mais ça me paraît un peu
problématique madame la ministre que se
passe-t-il à Sciences Po Poitiers
les étudiants dorénavant la possibilité
de suivre un cours sur la sociologie de
la race au programme les principes du
constructivisme racial la France face à
la race ou encore la blanchitée dans
l'hégémonie raciale et c'est vrai que
s'il y a la décolonisation des noms
d'oiseaux comme c'était le cas d'un
coloc bon
je suis pas persuadé que c'est un sujet
qui soit disons
susceptibles de nourrir un projet de
recherche financé par l'Union européenne
quoi qu'il est très intéressant de
constater que les noms d'oiseaux ont été
donnés par des explorateurs coloniaux
donc ça c'est ce constat est intéressant
mais faut-il pour autant décoloniser les
non-res on bascule ici de la théorie à
la pratique mais l'apport de
connaissance il est bon à prendre et moi
je n'ai aucune ironie à l'égard de ces
recherches donc oui il y a plein de
choses à prendre donc il faut certes
faire de l'autocritique c'est toujours
bon mais que c'est autotritique s'arrête
juste au moment de l'autodestruction
voilà juste ça
mais d'abord cette situation fermement
condamnée par la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur deux
enseignants de sciences Po Grenoble sont
accusés par certains étudiants d'être
fascistes et islamophobes fin novembre
l'école prépare une journée consacrée au
racisme à l'antisémitisme et à
l'islamophobie le professeur d'allemand
réfutent publiquement ce dernier terme
un débat s'engage par mails interposés
l'USI EPG syndica étudiant se dit alors
outré
clauskinzler enseigne l'allemand depuis
25 ans à l'IEP de Grenoble des affiches
placardées sur l'école jeudi dernier
l'accuse lui et un de ses collègues de
fascisme et d'islamophobie il s'estime
lâché par la direction ils sont
incapables de dire que je ne suis pas un
fasciste que je suis je ne suis pas un
islamophobe alors que tout le monde le
sait une quarantaine d'étudiants ont
dénoncé ce mardi les propos de deux
professeurs accusés d'islamophobie et
dont les noms ont été placardés sur la
façade quelques jours plus tôt nous
continuons à demander des sanctions tant
que ces deux professeurs ne se seront
pas excusés aujourd'hui ce qu'on a
cherché à faire c'est manifester notre
soutien aux personnes musulmanes qui
étaient victimes des discriminations de
la part de ce professeur et ses
professeurs réclament se réclament
disent qu'ils défendent la liberté
d'expression bah nous aujourd'hui on
fait exactement la même chose en marge
de cette mobilisation d'autres étudiants
regrettent cette dénonciation sur la
place publique
qui a conduit à la mise sous protection
des deux enseignants par le ministère de
l'Intérieur
c'était quand même 10 semaines après
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty ou un prof
donc est publiquement accusé de
islamophobie est un service à droite
islamophobe c'était un peu un peu quand
même problématique l'affaire cloud
c'est vraiment le laveur green à la
française c'est à dire que il y a
la même je dirais l'acheter
bureaucratique la même idée que face à
une foule lycheuse on va prendre parti
pour la foule et ce qui est intéressant
avec l'affaire kingsler c'est qu'on a
donc un pareil ça commence par un email
comme toujours ou qui se leur de façon
encore une fois très modérée très très
bien argumenté très bien pondéré
critique la notion d'islamophobie c'est
pas que je suis la vie que ce terme n'a
pas le droit d'exister on peut discuter
et donc je me suis dit je vais discuté
avec ce groupe sur le bien fondé de
cette intitulé dont je soupçonnais
connaissons mes collègues connaissant
mon IEP qu'il visait en fait
à banaliser les crimes de la Shoah et
qui visait à ériger
les musulmans français en victimes
comparable aux Juifs des années 30 en
Europe sur le concept d'islamophobie
bien qu'il y a encore débat je pense
qu'on peut se mettre d'accord que c'est
quand même encore un coup de génie des
barbus et des corbeaux iraniens en
l'occurrence de la révolution iranienne
la révolution islamique qui a eu en Iran
en 1979 mené par Robini c'est le fait
que être musulman se confond avec le une
race est un coulissamophobie est devenu
un racisme bon est-ce que être musulman
et c'est une race je pense le racisme
anti-arabe ou André maghrébin fait
largement l'affaire mais bon ils
tiennent beaucoup à avoir ce terme
souvent on entend islamophobie comme
étant le fait de critiquer l'islam on a
le droit de critiquer des religions donc
l'islamophobie 6 c'est en ce sens là me
paraît tout à fait légitime on a le
droit de critiquer des religions
critiques christianisme de critiquer le
judaïsme critiquer la religion en
général et comme l'islam est dans la
religion des eaux privés quand on
dégauchiste on peut abjurer en quelque
sorte ça détestation des religions en
disant ben voilà puisqu'ils sont
imprimés nous allons défendre cette
religion au nom de la lutte contre
l'impérialisme et donc l'impérialisme a
été le premier ferment de la jonction
entre l'anti impérialisme entre la
gauche et les religieux les islamistes
parinise n'étant plus porteur il leur
fallait trouver autre chose
[Musique]
je crois que c'est à ce moment-là que ce
concept d'islamophobie qui au début on a
choqué plus dedans et utiliser par des
hommes politiques alors qu'il n'a
absolument aucun sens
et maintenant il paraît tout à fait
normal à tout bout de champ de dire oh
mon dieu islamophobe et de toute
évidence cet tétanise le monde
occidental exactement comme une
accusation de racisme là-dessus à partir
de là il y a une sorte de complaisance à
l'égard de l'islamisme y compris dans
ces versions la plus radicale qui
consiste à considérer que au fond certes
il y a eu des attentats il y a eu tout
ça c'est bien malheureux mais il faut
les comprendre comme une forme de
réaction de légitime défense par rapport
à un oxydant qui est lui-même oppresseur
mais ce qu'on a vu à Grenoble de voir
des gamins de 18 19 20 ans non seulement
affiché le nom d'un professeur
on lui affûte blanc là le terme
d'islamophobie c'est autant dire de
racisme de fascisme de demander sa
démission de refuser de s'excuser de
tenir mordicus et
juste terrifiant jamais de la vie on
pourrait me traiter traiter de raciste
contre les musulmans j'ai dit X fois
dans mes mails aussi ça n'a rien à voir
je critique cette idéologie qui fait des
femmes des êtres de seconde zone et qui
convoquait aujourd'hui une biologie
dangereuse qui nous menace nouveau
rebondissements dans l'affaire de
l'Institut d'études politiques de
Grenoble l'enseignant accusé
d'islamophobie par certains étudiants en
début d'année est aujourd'hui suspendu
pour quatre mois par la direction de
l'IEP il sera bientôt convoqué devant un
conseil de discipline pour propos
diffamatoire tenu plusieurs médias
contre l'établissement et sa directrice
et ce qui est frappant avec Sciences Po
Grenoble c'est qu'on voit une
radicalisation progressive on voit
ensuite lorsqu'une fleur qui du coup
s'épanche dans les médias en disant ma
hiérarchie ne me soutient pas on voit ça
hiérarchie qui le suspend donc il a su
même l'attaque c'est même pas qu'il sait
même pas qu'ils l'ont pas défendu c'est
qu'ils l'ont attaqué en fait et par
dessus ça
fait passer en conseil de discipline les
jeunes qui ont mis ces affiches là et
donc qui ont mis en danger très
concrètement tu vois les étudiants sont
jugés par un conseil disciplinaire
délocalisé dans l'Université d'Auvergne
qui les relaxe parce que apparemment on
peut rien leur reprocher alors quand
c'est exactement qui a un non pas
affiché le nom mais qui a lancé ses
campagnes sur Facebook etc
[Musique]
en parallèle fort avec la question du
maoïsme dans le whoquisme l'opportunité
de subvertir de renverser les choses en
jouant la carte des jeunes garde rouge
contre les anciens
et on a vu des délations se mettent en
place comme à l'époque bah oui ou dans
le monde maoïste les jeunes devaient
rapporter des propos contre
révolutionnaires tenus par leurs parents
et donc c'est aux jeunes de rééduquer
les anciens ce qui vient inverser je
dirais le cours millénaire des choses
et là où c'est logique de purge et une
logique révolutionnaire c'est que c'est
souvent ceux qui sont en fait le plus
proche de ces idées là qui se font
purger en premier
dans la cancel culture donc la culture
de l'annulation qui est la méthode du
walkisme
de façon très publique c'est un signal
en fait envoyé au reste de l'espace
public
on fait disparaître
un membre et quand j'ai vu comme tout
les Français certaines
intellectuels français être
cancel ou dans certaines universités
quand il venaient faire des conférences
je dis que là on est très très mal parti
vous n'êtes pas tout à fait d'accord
avec nous vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
nous alors vous n'existez plus c'est la
mort sociale c'est insupportable c'est
pas comme ça qu'on va combattre le
racisme quand
ramaillade nous dit maintenant qu'elle
est aux extravail aux États-Unis qu'à
chaque fois qu'elle est passée devant la
statue de Colbert c'était une micro
agression
c'est tout à fait subjectif elle était
ministre de la République française
à cette culture venue des États-Unis wok
où il faut effectivement des boulonner
les statuts et elle se sent micro
agressées
[Applaudissements]
elle me fait absolument rien
même ceux qui veulent qu'on détruisent
des livres qu'on supprime certains
passages dans des films comme dans
Autant en emporte le vent on ne veut
plus que Scarlett O'Hara est
cette personne noire qui qui cette femme
noire qui travaille pour elle mais c'est
ça l'histoire de l'époque c'est comme ça
il faut qu'on voit les choses qu'on les
situe à l'époque où c'est arrivé et je
pense que aller commencer à gommer une
partie de l'histoire à débloquer des
statues c'est c'est abandonné l'idée que
l'éducation a un pouvoir incroyable que
l'éducation nous permet de réfléchir que
nous sommes des êtres qui pensent qui
peuvent avoir un sens critique qui
peuvent comprendre ce qui s'est passé
analyser ce qui s'est passé et donc moi
je pense que les gens qui qui se sentent
agressés par des statues ce sont des
gens qui sont intellectuellement
anesthésiés auto-anesthésier et qui ne
veulent pas qui ne veulent pas se
concentrer sur les vrais problèmes
d'aujourd'hui qui est une excuse pour
pour juste jouer la victime quoi
[Applaudissements]
un poème pendant le début de la
présidence de Joe Biden
et la traduction au Pays-Bas et en
Flandre a posé problème parce qu'ils
n'ont pas voulu qu'une personne blanche
traduise le poème parce qu'elle n'aurait
pas compris ce que ressent une femme
noire américaine ce qui est complètement
fou quiconque essaie de passer d'une
d'une couleur à une autre est
immédiatement vouée au gémonie et tout
simplement parce que la couleur noire
c'est la couleur de la victime et donc
c'est un blanc veut devenir noir ça veut
dire que l'usure peut son rôle il fait
de l'appropriation culturelle il fait de
l'appropriation épidermique et donc il
doit être immédiatement renvoyé à son
statut je suis assez étonné moi quand
même un de ces personnes qui se disent
antiraciste qui sont dans des
associations antiracistes
parce que si on regarde le réel elles
ont fait quoi depuis 30 ans avec cette
montée de l'extrême droite elles ont
fait quoi
souvent me dit mais en réalité tu es
dans le déni des discriminations ça
c'est dérangeant et c'est très perfide
et c'est très pervers et c'est très
malsain c'est parce que je lutte contre
les discriminations que je me refuse à
entrer sur ce chemin là du
décolonialisme parce que ça comme c'est
faux
ça attise la haine du côté de l'extrême
droite
couz usine chose
[Musique]
nous sommes ici pour tout changer c'est
important que vous le sachiez on ne
croit pas aux réforme nous croyons à
l'abolition de la démocratie
[Applaudissements]
c'est important de comprendre que
quelque chose doit naître et grandir ici
abolir la démocratie c'est ça c'est
déconstruire pour reconstruire
des couilles
view the sciente
solution
quelque soit les défauts de la société
française
évidemment nous avons pas de leçon à
recevoir des Américains surtout pas deux
à mon sens le malheur américain c'est
qu'il combattent à ségrégation par une
une sorte d'apartheid institué par
exemple recensement aux États-Unis se
fait sur les débats ethniques raciales
religieuses ou sexuelle et donc chacun
est ramené à sa couleur de peau à son
origine à sa croyance ou à son
orientation sexuelle alors qu'en
principe un recensement doit inclure
tous les citoyens d'un pays dans la
vision de l'universalisme républicain
français
il ne faut pas percevoir votre mesure la
race c'est à dire que on juge quelqu'un
selon le principe méritocratique
républicain évidemment la méritocratie
ne fonctionne pas toujours mais là ce
qui est très différent
c'est que
l'idée même d'être récompensé au mérite
disparaît dans le vaucisme c'est à dire
que même en entreprise vous allez
fonctionner intégralement par un système
de quota ou la personne à mettre un
poste clé n'est pas la personne
compétente n'est pas la personne
méritante n'est pas la personne
excellente et je crois que c'est c'est
vraiment un message de défaitiste et
dans ce sens là c'est dangereux parce
que si on nourrit si mes parents
m'avaient élevé comme ça je n'aurais
jamais imaginé que je suis capable de
faire un bon du bon travail que je suis
capable de mériter une promotion
j'aurais juste attendu et si je ne l'ai
pas ce que je veux je peux jouer la
victime en disant que c'est la faute des
autres donc moi ce que je voudrais c'est
qu'on envoie un message positif à la
jeunesse il faut travailler dur il faut
être optimiste il faut être ouvert à la
vie et vous allez pouvoir réaliser vos
rêves quel que soit votre couleur de
peau à l'origine c'était pas mal du tout
ce qu'on appelait wow aux États-Unis
dans les années 60- c'était vraiment un
appel
je dirais à la fois au cœur au cœur
battant des des non racisés comme disent
à faire attention
à faire attention à eux le wokisme
prospère en effet sur
les manquements de la promesse
républicaine d'égalité d'égalité des
chances et de la méritocratie on nous a
promis l'égalité et pourtant partout on
se tourne l'égalité n'est pas atteint
mais là où il faut faire une nuance une
distinction importante c'est que ils ne
sont pas en train de dire comme l'avait
fait intelligemment Martin Luther King
votre système votre promesse votre idéal
est beau simplement je trouve que vous
ne l'avez pas atteint je vais vous
encourager je vais vous pousser à être
cohérent avec vos promesses
là c'était pas ce qu'ils disent là ce
qu'il dit c'est que structurellement
fondamentalement votre système est
mauvais et cette rupture avec
l'universalisme et quelque chose
de radicalement nouveau en France en
fait
et avec des conséquences dramatiques ils
sont pas c'est pas des républicains
déçus si vous voulez c'est des gens qui
pensent que la République c'est un truc
de blanc dans le fond que c'est un truc
masculin que c'est pas du tout universel
même dans son essence quand vous
regardez l'histoire la liberté c'est
l'exception la tyrannie c'est la règle
donc ça nous rappelle un peu que dans un
microcosme comme Dieu p comme dans une
société tout entière cette liberté elle
n'est pas garantie en fait et donc il
faut défendre l'idéal républicain car il
est le seul compatible avec l'idée de la
démocratie l'idée de l'émancipation
[Musique]
en 84 à Paris
il nous expliquait deux choses sur la
Société française des dis quand je suis
arrivé en France je crois que c'était en
1948 il était misérable il n'avait pas
un saut en poche il m'a dit ce qui m'a
frappé c'est que les Français étaient
complètement indifférent il ne me voyait
pas il y a 30 ans c'était
sûr de mon avenir et je suis venu en
France franchement uniquement pour
quitter les États-Unis
[Musique]
parce que je pouvais pas je pouvais plus
supporter
[Musique]
il était homosexuel il m'a dit les
Français sont fichaient complètement il
m'a dit c'est indifférence m'a sauvé en
Amérique j'étais immédiatement
stigmatisé soit comme soit comme noir
soit comme homosexuel en France je
n'étais pas regardé et il dit les
Français m'ont délivré des béquilles de
la race alors ça c'est un mot
fondamental les béquilles de la race
c'est-à-dire on a besoin d'une béquille
racialiste pour expliquer la marche du
monde et dit en France a marché
autrement
[Musique]